first of all what you make of the
government's response to the appalling
tragedy that we've seen at Granville
town it is an appalling tragedy as a
London MP my heart goes out to all those
people I wrote a piece today about about
the tragedy in about what we should be
doing now my sense is the government's
right to have ordered a full public
enquiry straight away it's also right to
put immediately five million up I'm sure
there'll be more money following that
straight away so guarantees about that
guarantees about localized movements so
in other words nobody moving beyond the
local area the key question is
organising this initial response and
today it became clear that the local
authority there had really not been able
to get this organisation properly done
it's right therefore to move civil
servants in other councils around London
that have a greater experience of this
they should have accepted their help
earlier but it's right to therefore make
that change now so it's a very very
difficult circumstance you know this is
a tragedy bar none possibly the worst
that we've seen in non terrorist
activity in the UK so it's the right
thing to make those decisions that we
made already but I obviously our heart
and all the help goes out to them as
much as we possibly can
of course now in the Sunday time today
conservative sources are quoted saying
that they want to do an IDs on the prime
minister in other words forcing a vote
of no-confidence to try and oust her now
it happened to you do you see it
happening to tourism eh no not at all I
don't know where who these people are by
the way and you know these things happen
in general times but I was course I was
leader of the Opposition wasn't leader
of the government
Teresa may has come out of an election
we didn't do as well as we're obviously
hopeful which is a probability under
statement but the reality is that we
need stability now and we don't need
silly people in the Conservative Party
with big mouths and small brains running
around the place trying to tell
everybody what they're going to do I
think what they should do now is do what
the rest of us want to do which is try
and support the government because the
Whig threat you know you look into the
abyss and it grins back at you with a
short crop grey beard and a very Marxist
ideology so we don't want to see that
govern Britain and therefore we have to
get stable get behind the Prime Minister
and make sure that at the end of it all
that
has the strength and the potency to be
able to go on and govern as her
government does now do you think that is
partly why people are backing to resume
at the moment after that pretty
disastrous electoral results because
they're so worried about another
election in Jeremy Corbyn getting into
power well first of all we won the
election
I mean whichever way you cut it we are
the largest party
I know it's but you could argue that you
didn't actually win the election
although you just remember the lots of
times on a second just imagine if we'd
come from opposition to this position
you'd say oh you won the election my
point is we did not do as well as we'd
hoped we wanted a full working majority
we didn't get that but what we did get
was the largest vote ever and also we
are the largest party so the maths are
that we should be forming the government
and that's what she's doing I know it's
difficult for Jeremy Corbyn to add this
all up but the reality is we are the
ones that are in government and we
should stand government and we should
govern carefully for the whole nation
and that we have now pressing on us is
two years of negotiation on the European
Union to leave and we need to start that
as soon as possible Monday and we need
to get behind the government while we do
that and stop messing around let's talk
about those brexit talks of course as
you say do to kick off and you know
tomorrow
now Tories may call the election to try
and increase her mandate for her
position on brexit she ended up losing
seats does that mean that the government
needs to soften or change its approach
to leaving the EU no we've got to be
very clear can I just first of all say
hard and soft are ridiculous terms
because you ask anybody do you want
something that's really hard they're
gonna know if you want something that's
really soft they say yes but what does
it mean it doesn't mean anything at all
we stood on a manifesto by the way the
Labour Party stood on all that's exactly
the same manifesto which is take back
control of our borders our laws our
money leaving the single market leaving
the customs union why is that important
because leaving the customs union gives
us the prize of setting trade deals
around the rest same time if you didn't
really like your manifesto very much
today that's when the poll figure on a
second
Labour stood on exactly the same
manifesto and it's interesting that that
was confirmed again this week by them
that they would be leaving the single
market and leaving the customs union so
86 percent of the public voted for
manifestos are contained leaving the
single market and leaving the customs
union now that's the initiation of the
the negotiation and obviously in all of
this will be doing bits and
trade offs but the key thing is we have
a clear agenda we should get on with it
and for those who say you didn't well
they need to read both those manifestos
as interesting was made clear down with
John MacDonald made it clear again this
morning because I didn't hear his
interview but we had the Chancellor on
Mar making it very clear today that he
stood by our manifesto position and the
likes to house speech that was made by
trees in May so we are united in that
just need to get on talking about and
Philip Hammond appearance that early
wrong cuz he was sort of talking about
the UK leaving the customs union leaving
at the single market who's also hinting
at quite a long transitional arrangement
would you be happy with that I didn't
I've always been a great believer that
I'll support whatever they get out of
the negotiation because the public voted
to leave but we obviously want to remain
at the end of the day friends with our
allies in the European Union you know
some of my family live in Italy I
studied out there I have huge affection
for the Europeans countries friends are
there's were allies of theirs we want to
stay involved with them on
anti-terrorist activity and we want to
trade with them still now it may be as
Pascal Lamy said a few months ago we end
up with a deal that says we have zero
four zero trade we have an agreement to
have access to services but we may take
a little bit longer to thrash out all
the details of the trade deal but what
we don't want to have is as we leave
trade barriers is not in their interest
and it's not in ours the problem is of
course getting to its negotiation you
actually got a weaker hand than before
the election because the smaller
majority already looks as though the UK
government is weakening its position on
the order that we talk about things does
that worry you no not really I don't
think so I don't think it's any weaker
or any stronger the idea of the election
was not to get strength in the European
Union but to make sure we could get all
the bills and legislation through here
at home in the European Union they have
a simple point we're leaving they voted
for it and that's what we're going to be
doing discussing negotiating that in the
way that we said in the manifesto in
Duncan Smith thank you very much for
your time I visited